[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and a
couple years ago in 2014 samsung made a
surprise product announcement called the
galaxy note edge with this crazy display
hanging off one side and for a random
unexpected phone it got a lot of
attention since then that product has
evolved again and again into samsung's
entire flagship lineup which brings us
to the galaxy s8 so this new phone looks
awesome and that's its hallmark
headlining feature is how good it looks
and how well it's designed and then of
course being a flagship it has all the
bleeding edge specs inside and the
hardware you'd expect from a premium
android phone so is this the complete
package like the ultimate smartphone
almost
it's almost it's almost there so let me
start by saying i love this phone's
build like pretty much everything about
the outside of this phone is premium and
well-built and awesome the display up
front sort of melts over both sides and
it does so smoothly into the back frame
while last year's phone did it more
sharply and if you want to talk about
modern or about the future of smartphone
design this year has been a shift to
these really tall displays making these
slightly taller candy bar shaped phones
now the best part of these super thin
bezels on all sides is that the
footprint of the phone shrinks a lot so
the 5.8 inch and 6.2 inch displays
respectively on the s8 and s8 plus don't
feel like huge phones even though they
have huge screens in fact the s8 i think
is a great size because it's so narrow i
might have big hands but i think even
anyone with regular hands can reach
across to the other side of this display
just maybe not all the way up to the top
and i think the best indicator for this
is the fingerprint sensor obviously
there's no more room to put it up at the
front of the phone so they moved it
around to the back but instead of
putting it somewhere in the middle of
the back they put it right up there next
to the camera now with most back
fingerprint sensors they're a little
lower on the phone for reachability just
the way you hold the phone makes it
easier now i think the top fingerprint
sensor might look a little bit better in
some cases but it is definitely harder
to reach even with my larger hands i
legit dislike this location i hold the
phone with my right hand so i'm reaching
the maximum distance up and over across
the phone over across the camera with my
finger and often i don't quite make it
or i touch the camera glass instead or i
only partially cover the fingerprint
sensor and the reader doesn't unlock it
doesn't work so this is through a week
of using the phone i'm sure i could get
used to it eventually but for most
people this just makes it a two-handed
phone and then you can end up just using
the phone with two hands all the time
now to be fair the glass over the camera
actually does a good job deflecting
smudges that come from errant
fingerprint unlocks but honestly a
clever way to get past this is with a
case or better yet a skin actually so
this is the skin from dbrand and not
only is it better for gripping this all
glass phone but the tiny depth
difference actually lets you better
distinguish the fingerprint sensor from
the camera on the back so fun fact
highly recommended either way samsung's
word on this is now they provide you
with a bunch of other ways to unlock
your phone biometrically that don't use
a fingerprint sensor mainly being the
iris scanner and the face unlock now i
didn't expect to like this answer mainly
because the face unlock can literally be
tricked with a picture of you so that's
no good and the iris scanner usually
requires you holding it up at a weird
angle that you don't normally hold your
phone which is a little awkward but this
iris scanner i think it might have a
wider angle lens or the sensor has
improved something about it is better
because i don't quite have to hold it up
at that awkward angle anymore and it
does a pretty good job of unlocking my
phone when i'm not like trying to i set
it up i didn't expect to use it but a
lot of times i just hold the phone up
and start using it and it would unlock
for me so that actually turned out to be
a pleasant surprise either way aside
from the awkward tallness of the phone
and the fingerprint sensor the galaxy s8
is the best industrial design of any
smartphone in a long time in my opinion
even though there are other phones out
now and coming soon that do the tall
display thin bezels thing you still
gotta add on all metal and glass still
has expandable storage through a micro
sd card slot still fully water and dust
resistant ip68 certified so you can
spill water on it and it's cool it still
has usb type-c with quick charge still
has wireless charging still keeps the
headphone jack and the speaker is below
average and downward facing it might be
the worst part of the phone's build but
that comes with the territory when
there's no room on the front and you
kind of want to water seal your phone so
back to the screen it's incredible it is
i would say the best display on any
smartphone again it gets extremely
bright so it's visible outdoors or
whenever and it's an oled so of course
it has fantastic color and contrast
ratios and dynamic range and it's super
high resolution too we're talking 2960
by 1440 on both phones actually so all
that makes for an awesome media
experience a great web browsing
experience and great scrolling through
twitter and instagram and seeing a lot
of stuff at once experience and all of
samsung's software obviously supports it
perfectly now not every app in the app
store fills the display right now right
out the box like a lot of games
especially will have to be updated or
may just never fully support that so
you'll either have the black bars on
either side or you can punch in
and of course most videos also aren't in
this aspect ratio either so when
watching a video you'll get the black
bars as well unless you hit the button
in the software to punch in a little bit
but then you lose some of the frames so
it's kind of your call it's give a
little take a little for the slightly
taller display but overall i'll take it
i think the screen is awesome and with
its curved edges and curved corners i'm
a fan and then there is the inside of
the phone and since this is a flagship
samsung is again pushing things to the
highest end of what's available except
for one particular area but there's some
pretty high end specs in here snapdragon
835 adreno 540 gpu four gigabytes of ram
at least 64 gigs of storage which like
we said is expandable and this is the
first phone to ship with bluetooth 5.0
which i made an entire separate video
about that just dropped highly recommend
that so the performance aspect is pretty
much taken care of the same way it
always is great specs great speed and
animations out the box but nobody has
used this phone for a year or two yet so
we'll have to see how the samsung
software ages
and that's just what it is it's samsung
software on top of android 7.0 and it
has its pros and cons i actually like
that it's adapted to be more like nougat
with the swiping app drawer and the
cleaner overall look especially of the
settings app but it's really obviously
still samsung eyes with all the colors
and some interesting quirks here and
there with the paginated app drawer and
a couple extra animations nothing too
crazy or extra but it's not necessarily
better than not having it the edge
screen has gotten better there's now a
couple features like from the note with
smart select and the gif maker where you
can select part of your screen to make
an animation or even take round
screenshots all kinds of stuff that we
didn't have before so you know there's
interesting stuff you can put in there i
really like the extended screenshot
feature where you can take a screenshot
but then it gives you the option to
scroll down and extend that as much as
you want so i'm really glad that made
its way back into this phone but yeah
overall it's familiar to anyone who's
used a samsung phone in the last two or
three years both aesthetically and
functionally now one of the biggest new
features in the software department of
the galaxy s8 is called bixby you may
have heard of it it's the virtual
assistant that's built for this phone
that just does a lot of what google
assistant does now the circumstances
surrounding it are interesting because
samsung put a dedicated button on the
side of the phone just for launching it
a bixby button now a lot of people
didn't like this for fair reason whether
they didn't like bixby or didn't want it
so they found a way to use an app to
remap the bixby button to do whatever
they want probably should have been in
the samsung settings in the first place
you can make it the default for the
button sure but in in regions where
people don't use bixby or bixby is not
supported or language support's not
there yet or it's incomplete let them go
on the settings and remap it to whatever
they want it could be a legitimate
useful separate feature well yesterday
samsung actually patched that up and
blocked any remapping of that button at
all on the galaxy s8 so it's definitely
now just a bixby button so
understandably again people got kind of
angry about that nobody wants accidental
triggers of the app they want to never
use but a couple of people were asking
well hey what if what if bixby is
actually really great what if bixby is
amazing what if it's better than google
so i gave it that chance i didn't remap
my bixby button and i was using bixby
alongside this phone for the past week
and i'll give you that so first of all
the voice feature is not activated yet
and it won't get added till later this
year so that's a pretty rough start but
aside from that it does show you some
cards your gallery your upcoming
calendar events maybe some weather some
frequent contacts but then that pretty
quickly devolved into a bunch of samsung
apps like themes and wallpapers and
flipboard and a bunch of stuff i don't
use so really it's working in catch-up
mode to be able to do all that google
does with gmail and navigation cards and
flight status and all that now the one
place it did do some interesting stuff
is in the camera app in the viewfinder
there's a bixby button that if you press
it it can recognize images in the
viewfinder and search for them whether
it's images or if it's a product it will
get you amazon search to maybe buy it
i've seen google goggles try this a
couple years ago and with bixby it was
about the same pretty hit or miss
sometimes they would get it and it would
be pretty useful especially when there's
a lot of text to it that it can
recognize it just searches that text so
it makes sense that it would work there
other times when i thought it might get
it nothing came up or it got it wrong
with this bluetooth speaker for example
sometimes it got nothing sometimes it
thought it was a baseball hat i don't
know not sure how to get it to work
better but no dice so aside from this
biggest new software feature being kind
of a swing and a miss on this phone i'm
totally fine with the software on the s8
it's cleaner it's much more refined it's
out of the way i like it now the camera
on the back this has also been a bit of
a source of discussion at first it
wasn't really talked about and we kind
of assumed it was literally the exact
same camera as last year it has the same
specs no dual cameras like some of its
rivals it's a 12 megapixel f 1.7
aperture dual pixel auto focus optical
image stabilization top-notch stuff
again but yeah same as we've already
seen but turns out this is a slightly
updated sensor with newer optics so the
images will look slightly different from
the galaxy s7 honestly most of the
difference will come from better image
processing but the photos and 4k videos
from galaxy s8 look fantastic as you
would expect maybe leave a comment if
you want a direct comparison to its
predecessor but you can imagine you can
see the samples great detail great
contrast color and sharpness are
excellent and pretty aggressive auto hdr
modes so dynamic range is also pretty
wide rarely blows out the highlights
like a lot of other phones would so of
course it's a pleasure to take photos
and videos with such a nice screen as a
viewfinder we often say the best camera
is the one you have with you i think
this is no exception with this phone
it'll be one of the best cameras you can
put in your pocket again this year now
battery life is one area where i would
have wanted just a little bit more now
this is samsung we're talking about here
and they just had one of their phones
last year literally start exploding when
they tried to push the battery to the
limit so i almost can't blame them for
playing it safe this year but yeah the
three thousand milliamp hour battery on
the galaxy s8 i was testing pretty much
barely got me through the end of the day
maybe ten percent left when i'm done and
to be fair i'm pretty heavy on it i use
it a lot bright screen lots of video
watching taking pictures etc for the
review but there are phones with
definitely better battery life as i
suspected the upside though is that it
charges ridiculously fast i had a night
where i went to sleep with 22
and i woke up in the morning with 8 so
that's pretty terrible standby time and
i was going to start the day with the
battery dead but i threw it on the
charger for about an hour left with a
hundred percent battery no problem so
you kind of pick your battles there uh
samsung just played it safe with the
battery so at the end of the day the
galaxy s8 is awesome and it's so samsung
that this this project was born from the
crazy like back burner pet project that
was the galaxy note edge and now every
phone like this has this crazy edge
display and i'm glad they keep doing
that stuff and you got to give samsung
credit for making a phone that can stand
out for how good it looks in an era well
this little mini era where so many
phones are accused of all looking the
same this one actually does stand out in
a pretty awesome way and i like that a
lot about it there may be little things
you don't like about it little
unmappable buttons little software
quirks here and there maybe the speaker
is not the best but as a complete
package this is an awesome phone i
recommend it i've said the word awesome
so many times you probably can
understand that i like this already
and i'd recommend it i'll have links
below for other stuff you want to check
out but that's pretty much it thank you
for watching talk to you guys in the
next one
peace
[Music]